after 95 uncanny years spent imagining
his way to the top of the world
Stanley passed away on November 12th
2018 it's only now that what appears to
be the final cameo from the Marvel
Comics figurehead is seen release and
the story of that cameo appearance may
surprise you for one thing it's not in a
Marvel movie if you know Stanley you've
probably also heard of Jason Mewes as
far as fan bases are concerned there's a
lot of overlap there news came up as an
actor in the 90s as the taller lankier
louder half of Jay and Silent Bob the
dynamic duo of drug dealers who helped
tie together the early films of Ryder
director Kevin Smith aka Silent Bob
after preparing for the project since
2016 Jason Mewes has finally launched
his own directorial debut feature
madness and the method to be released in
theaters and on demand on August 2nd
2019 after charting an unexpected path
through show business toward statuses at
bonafide icon Muse was able to call on
many other pop culture players for help
when it came time to direct his own
movie that roster includes Stan Lee who
agreed to shoot what news calls his
favorite scene in the movie not just for
the contents of the sequence but for the
fact that Lee came out to do the scene
at all we sat down with Muse for an
exclusive interview and he described the
experience of filming Lee as being quote
just surreal the opportunity came
together in a rapid fashion that
required the movie's crew to rush in
three-and-a-half hours early in order to
set up lead shots and for a heartwarming
reason - he had to be out of there by
5:30 because he will not miss dinner
with his wife every night at 6 o'clock
he has dinner at his wife and he will
not miss that her name was Joan and I
took Joanie to lunch and then we got
married it was a good lunch to see what
Stan Lee's seen in madness in the meth
that actually entails you'll have to
watch the movie for yourself but it
shouldn't be too surprising that the
sequence at least partially involves Lee
delivering a personal insult to Jason
Mewes Jason Mewes that smoochie Buchi
guy but that animosity is just a product
of a screenplay according to muse the
real-life Lee was a saint on set asking
little in return for his appearance in
the film to me which seems such like a
sweet gesture for him to like roll out
of his house
come down and be in a movie and when
he's not getting paid a bunch of money
and just to be like hey we're gonna do
this favor for Muse so to me it was like
literally a favor like just like hey we
want to be in Jays movie he's a nice kid
we've known him since Mallrats since 90
whatever it just will always be you know
a special awesome moment for me one
aspect that makes the experience so
special is the distinct likelihood of it
being Lee's last cameo unless some
hidden material in the Disney Vault Seas
released someday and Avengers 9 I don't
know for sure but it's what it seems
like that is the lot my movie is the
last movie he shot it's just really
amazing that he did that muse met
Stanley for the first time back when
Stanley cameos weren't really a thing it
was 1995 on the set of Mallrats Kevin
Smith's second movie and the first to be
produced by a major studio clerks was
the first movie but to me really Moritz
is our first movie my first movie
because it was like that it became real
to come a Minnesota staying in a hotel
and and there's wardrobe and their stunt
guys and you know I get to hang from a
grappling hook and I get to meet Stanley
for the first time it would probably
have come as a surprise to the younger
Muse to learn that he would go on to
meet Lee over and over again in the
years to come as the two toured the same
circles at comic book conventions and
movie sets but that doesn't mean he's
not still proud of his poster from all
rats signed by Lee himself it's like
when I first met Stan I think I got
something signed way back in 95 or so
when we made made Morris cuz I was so
excited that first piece of memorabilia
got unfortunately misplaced but no
matter they'd meet again
you saw him many many times after that
at different comic book conventions we
did an Audi commercial Kevin directed
Stan was there their relationship came
full circle when Lee made an appearance
reading the script for Mallrats in 2019
s Captain Marvel effectively
immortalizing the movie and news himself
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe though
Muse may have had the privilege of
directing Stan Lee in his own movie
that's not necessarily his favorite of
Lee's cameos
my favorite he does so many it does so
many awesome ones some fans may love the
one in the Amazing Spiderman in which
Lee appears as a librarian blissfully
arranging books with headphones on
while spider-man and the lizard tear up
the room behind him others may enjoy the
moment in the Incredible Hulk in which
Lee accidentally drinks a soda tainted
with Bruce banners radioactive blood but
the one that comes to Muses mind as a
favorite cameo is from another movie
helmed by longtime collaborator Kevin
Smith you know I really liked his cameo
in Kevin's movie yoga hosers he picks up
the phone he's like what the hell what
he says exactly but it was really sweet
specifically Lee is seen picking up the
phone as a police dispatcher in the teen
horror movie listening to the
protagonists tone sounding ramblings
about little sausage men that looked
like Adolf Hitler in Lee's book one of
history's worst villains well he sure is
a nasty temper worse than Doctor Doom
and Darth Vader combined he then
provides the movie's titular line as an
insult god Bo Cohoes errs when it comes
to Stan Lee cameos it's harder to tell
what the future holds than you might
think
footage may exist that we don't know
about planned for use in future films in
ways we can't predict but for now it
sure seems like madness and the method
is set to be Lee's last role not that
people haven't been wrong before
directors Anthony and Joe Russo have
implied in the past that least cameo for
endgame was the last one he shot well
that's an assertion contradicted by the
fact that Lee's cameo / Captain Marvel
was actually filmed after that of course
Captain Marvel was released before end
game and both films came out months
before madness in the method even though
the madness cameo was probably shot
first it's confusing when it comes to
footage we don't know about floating
around it's entirely possible that
madness and the method may just feature
the last Stan Lee cameo to come out this
year but for now as far as anyone can
tell Jason Mewes his directorial debut
holds the last bit of cameo footage to
be released of a media magnate who
became a surprising applause worthy
presence on the silver screen have you
seen this cameo yet you have I haven't
seen it yet is it
the only reason I came was to Zima cameo
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]